- He is my favorite late, late night host.
You can see him every weekday night
on NBC in his very own show,
Late Night with Seth Meyers.
If you haven't seen it, you're dumb,
you should check it out.
Give it up for Seth Meyers
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Yes! How are you?
- I'm wonderful, how are you doing?
- I'm a little tired
today, but that's okay.
Did you, you knew that
Bobcat story though,
that we just told?
- Yeah. Happy, I heard Happy's in studio.
- Yes. Happy is in studio.
So I'm just saying we
still have him on the line,
do you have any other questions for him?
I know that you've already covered this.
- Yes. First of all, I just
wanna say thank you to happy,
We very much like talking about
your exploits on television.
Did the Bobcat's tooth
actually hit your knuckle bone
or was it just the knuckle
part of the finger?
- No, it actually it stuck me in the bone.
I could feel it in the bone.
- Wow! That sucks! (laughing)
- I mean, Happy, you are a legend.
You are a legend, my friend,
because that makes me think
that you knew you were throwing a Bobcat
which was an incredible throw by the way,
whose tooth might've been
attached to your knuckle bone.
- I wouldn't go that far,
but, you know, but yeah.
- I would've tossed that
thing as far away from me
as possible, like you
don't belong here, sir.
Yeah. You're in my territory.
- You don't mess with my wife.
- Yeah. I know. I love that
part, that was so sweet.
Alright...
- My wife has said to me
that the best I could
do was say, shoo, shoo.
(Kelly laughing)
- That's not true.
So wait, do you like not having
to wear a suit every day?
- It's great, I feel like, you know,
I got into comedy which is not a suit job
and then I was lucky enough
to be a Weekend Update anchor
and then that's a pretend suit job.
And then you get late night
and now it's a full suit job
because at Weekend Update,
we're wearing a lot of jeans
underneath the desk.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And this has been a real reminder
of why I didn't wanna work at a bank.
I love not wearing a suit.
And it's a lot easier getting dressed
when you don't have to put a tie on.
- Well, my personal favorite
part of all of this,
attire wise, is people keep
saying, "oh my gosh, like,
I don't even know what it's
like to dress up anymore
'cause I'm just like wearing
like, you know, athleisure,
like casual clothes all the time."
And I'm like welcome to being a musician,
that's like, for the past
20 years I've lived on a bus
in one suitcase, wearing
the same pajamas every day
because you wear what you wear on stage
and then you wear normal clothes,
you're just hanging on the bus.
So like literally I have been
in COVID attire for 20 years now.
Like that's what I've been living.
- Now, Kelly, did you ever, were you ever
like a multiple costume
change concert type of act?
- Yes. Unfortunately, yes.
- What's the most you wore
on stage in one night?
- Maybe five and that's a lot.
I'm good with like three
'cause I don't like to
take the time to do it
'cause I'm more worried about my vocals,
I don't think people are
coming to my show to be like,
"I wonder what she's wearing."
Like so much as they are
like how I'm gonna sound.
So yeah.
- Right.
- I could be wrong.
I could just be lazy.
- I think you're right
and I think it's true.
People are there for your talent
and look, if you wanna put
on three outfits for them,
I'm sure they're not gonna mind.
- Yeah, I mean it's so time-consuming
but anyway, yes, I've done it.
Okay. So I have to ask,
where are you calling from?
'Cause it's kind of like
the saddest room ever,
I'm just gonna let you know right now.
- [Seth] Okay.
- Yeah.
- Thank you for that feedback.
Before you say that you did
notice the one plant, right?
- The single plant of the
sign of life in the room.
- Yeah.
(Kelly laughing)
- There were more
plants, but they all left
'cause it was so depressing.
We had to nail that one to the table.
- You're the show with
like, just the one fern .
- I'm actually, I am in a really
corporate-y conference room,
which is where we used to
have like writer's
meetings and now is empty,
so we set it up for
this but yeah I agree...
- I love that your writers'
rooms, by the way though,
are the most creative looking
room in the world. (laughing)
- Well, there actually is
usually like fun stuff behind us,
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Behind me on the wall,
that's like writer's room based
but a lot of it's really
inappropriate for television.
- Okay. So wait, when you
were on my show last spring
I confessed my love of
cleaning out my ears,
it's weird how much I love to do it,
but what's one habit of yours
that you would like to confess now?
Do you have one?
That's weird?
- I'm surprised I haven't
confessed it to you before
but have I told you how
much I love to floss?
- You do?
- I love to floss.
I'll eat food that gets stuck in my teeth,
just for the purposes of flossing.
- Oh wait, are you making fun of me?
- No, I love to floss.
Do you not like to floss?
- I don't know if I'm like the best person
that comes to the dentist.
Usually I'm the one that
leaves and they're like,
"you can floss a little more."
I'm still a child.
- But see, for me, it's not
like the maintenance flossing,
like the, you know, I know
you're supposed to like floss
at the end of the night.
I only like flossing if like,
I know there's something
in there. So like for me...
- It's getting it out.
- I'll like buy a bag of
jerky and a thing of floss
and that's just like my afternoon.
- Well, first of all, I'm
definitely down for the jerky
'cause that's awesome.
But that's, you're right, that is weird.
So I don't know anybody that loves that.
But what what's up for this summer?
- I don't know, it seems
like weird that, like,
the cleaning her ears lady
is gonna look down her nose
at the guy who flosses, but whatever.
- Oh no, here's the thing, you know,
you should look down at
me, people it feels good.
You're right, I'm the weird one here.
Okay. (laughing) So
what's up for this summer
because we're starting
to get our lives back,
are y'all gonna do, do
y'all take vacation?
Do y'all do that kind
of thing, like go big?
- Yeah, we'll go spend
some time with my in-laws
and they're near a beach, which is great.
I'm not very handy
and my father-in-law,
Tom is incredibly handy
and he other day, my son
found a piece of wood
that he wanted to turn
into a boat and he said,
"I am sad that you don't
know how to build things
but I am lucky that grandpa does."
I don't know why I had
to get dragged into this.
- That's amazing and so sad.
Well, not many can widdle,
not many can do that, so.
- No but he does.
He has like, his grandfather
has a full like, you know,
work shed and I think it's
every, my boys just love that
they're gonna spend the summer
getting to build projects with him.
- No, that is super cool.
I do love though, that we have
figured out in this interview
that you won't save
your wife from a Bobcat
and you can't help your son
build anything. That's awful.
- Well I'm busy flossing.
- So wait, this is, I love this.
Is it true that your dad had one rule
for you when you were a kid?
Like if you were going to lie,
like if you got in trouble,
if you're gonna lie, it had
to be a really good lie?
- Yeah. He hated when we lied
in a way that disrespected
his intelligence.
I remember one time, the first time
he left my brother and I alone for a week,
my parents went on a trip
and we were probably,
let's say 15 and 13.
And then he came home and
he said, "where's the mail?"
And we had cleaned up really fast
and we couldn't remember
where we put the mail
'cause the house was a real mess.
And so I said to my dad,
"we didn't get any mail."
And he said, "for the first time ever,
we went five straight days
without getting any mail?"
And I said, "yeah, no mail
came this entire week."
And then he sat on the couch
and there was a giant lump
because my brother had shoved all the mail
under a couch cushion.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- I love that, your dad,
that must be where you get your humor,
he was like "so for five solid
days, nothing, not a bill?"
- So that was it, so the first time ever
we didn't even get a catalog? Okay.
- Sure.
- That's an incredible coincidence.
My mom loves nothing more
than when she's around
the two of us and my dad.
She like piles on my dad
because she thinks like my
brother and I will back her up
and we have to say, "Hey,
I think what would be great
for this time where we're all together is
if you were a little
less critical of dad."
(Kelly laughing)
- No, 'cause then all
the fun would disappear.
- She literally like walks
in the door and she's like,
"you're not gonna believe what
this guy did on the drive."
And we're like, "relax."
- Oh, she likes the story.
Well, before you go,
I asked Jimmy and Maya
whenever they were here,
memories of Prince, you know
because I heard about the huge
40th anniversary SNL party
and it sounds like the most
epic party in all of the lands,
so what do you remember about that night?
- Well, I mean, it was
the party that only exists
in like works of fiction.
We never would have that
many people together again
but I remember my wife and I
were weaving through the crowd
right as prince was on stage.
And it's very strange,
you never think of like
famous people going like this,
"Excuse me, excuse me."
But it was so densely packed
and I was doing the excuse me
and then just came like, you know,
my face came like this close to Beyonce
and we were, you know,
our eyes met and I just was like,
"pretty cool party, right?"
And she said, "yeah."
And then we just kept going,
like the momentum took us away.
(Kelly laughing)
And my wife said, "wow, you
really killed that interaction."
- Nailed it. (laughing)
oh my gosh, and then she said hi...
- You better leave your ringer on
'cause you probably gonna
get a call from Beyonce.
- She said, hi, and then I
said, hi, and then it was over.
That was awesome.
- Yeah. I said, I dunno
if you heard, I was like,
"pretty cool party, right?"
And then she was like, "yeah."
And then like, we went pretty good.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- All right, Late Night with Seth Meyers
airs weeknights on NBC.